NetherRealm has been on a roll since
2011's Mortal Kombat reboot with the
release of injustice to its come one
step closer to perfecting its particular
brand of fighting you injustice too is
dense deep and refined but also
accessible to newcomers but it's the
addition of gear that makes the biggest
splash allowing you to craft a
personalized hero or villain there are
some complications to gear management
that may frustrate but minor gripes
aside this RPG like progression system
proves to be the biggest boon for an
already strong fighting game set in a
fractured DC Comics universe you're
supposed to be my friend which is why I
have to stop you the cast of characters
sees the return of many familiar faces
but also introduces unlikely fan
favorites such as the blood barfing red
lantern Atrocitus and the plant-based
behemoth Swamp Thing the nearly 30
characters offer a broad range of
superpowers and fighting styles and each
has a distinct trait that can instantly
trigger a status buff or summon an
underling in the middle of a fight you
meet many of these fighters in an
impressive story mode which showcases in
other realms trademark theatrics
I forgot to bring my banana arrow wait
you eat bananas right or is that an
offensive stereotype both in cutscenes
and in battle DC's cast has never looked
better but the real star of the show is
the fighting system which consists of a
mix of hand-to-hand combat superpowers
weapons and environmental hazards
how characters fit into these styles of
combat differs but as is the norm for
nether realms games most attacks feel
hefty and deliberate at first special
moves and combos are easy enough to
learn but it takes time and practice to
get combo timing under your skin to move
fluidly from one attack to the next
[Music]
still newcomers can easily impress each
other with simple to button super moves
that pause the action for an absurd and
cinematic combo attack or halt an
incoming combo attack by activating
clash a move that forces players to
gamble segments of their super meter in
hopes of regaining health or inflicting
extra damage in the hands of a new
player clashing can provide an escape
plan in the hands of a pro it opens up a
mind game that can drastically alter the
playing field ultimately there's no
better teacher for a new player than
experienced in this sense injustice 2 is
packed with learning opportunities in
the multiverse a mode that benefits from
randomly generated battle modifiers and
the temptation of gear based rewards not
all multiverse challenges are enjoyable
but you sometimes get a satisfying leg
up over the competition regardless of
whether modifiers make the act of
fighting more or less difficult they
nevertheless serve as a valuable
opportunity to see your characters
abilities under a new lens and study
their potential perhaps more importantly
depending on your love for loot the
multiverse is your primary means of
acquiring gear item boxes and experience
points specific types of gear are often
teased before you choose a mission and a
shiny new helmet for dr. fate or a sword
for Wonder Woman for example can often
prove to be rewarding enough to put up
with the game's more troublesome
modifiers otherwise random gear drops
after individual battles and blind loot
boxes are rewarded based on a score
derived from how efficiently and
dominantly you fight with five gear
slots extra ability slots and custom
shading unlocks for each character
there's a lot of character specific gear
to collect by default gear is
distributed in a multiverse with a
slight bias towards the character you're
playing regardless you will ultimately
earn items for other characters
practically to the point that you rarely
get what you're actually looking for
even when that unexpected epic grade
item drops for your favorite hero you
may then find that it's still
temporarily out of reach as all gear is
level locked that is unless you have
enough funds to get around this pesky
rule injustice 2's currency system has
many layers but can be broken down into
two use cases spending relatively common
credits skilled credits and region
tokens to earn random gear or regenerate
items you already own and trading in
source crystals which can cost
real-world money to have total control
over items in your inventory in the
latter scenario you are spending large
amounts of a valuable resource to use or
manipulate
items that you already own though you
can earn some source crystals by playing
injustice to over dozens of hours they
come few and far between to seemingly
make spending real-world money seem like
a necessary evil but this misgiving
aside you can still get a lot of
enjoyment out of collecting gear and
outfitting characters without spending
additional cash watching a character's
traditional outfit transform into
something fresher unexpected and seeing
their stats grow through leveling up and
equipping gear grants is satisfying
sense of ownership over your
accomplishments and possessions your
character's appearance will carry over
to every mode but stat boosts only count
in unranked online matches when both
players agree and never in ranked
matches this allows multiverse to serve
as the anything-goes variety show
without negatively impacting the
competitive community with the rewards
you earn the introduction of automated
AI battles is a nice touch for people
who want a taste of online competition
without the pressure to train and master
a character and is an easy way to earn
free item boxes every day after creating
a team of three fighters who retain any
and all stat boosts you pit them against
another player's online team and watch
fights play out in front of you you can
also rely on other players to fight your
AI team while you're away from the game
you retain a win-loss record and are
often treated item boxes whenever you
log in an occurrence that will fluctuate
based on how often your team defeats
incoming challenges while you're offline
let's warm up Victor yeah but you don't
strain yourself that's never been a
problem with AI battles online in local
versus matches the ever-changing
multiverse and an impressive story mode
and justice - offers numerous ways of
engaging with its characters and testing
your abilities without feeling
repetitive with over 25 characters to
explore with hundreds of pieces of gear
to collect it's easy to look forward to
watching your next character grow while
your inventory and understanding of
mechanics continues to expand another
realm has delivered a fighting game that
can be enjoyed by new players and pros
alike in ways that go beyond pure
competition it's a bar that every
fighting game should meet but one that
is up until now seemed out of reach
[Music]
[Music]